um so you're probably wondering why I
have a cushion on my head though to be
honest in a second the cushion is
probably going to be the least of your
worries I'm about to do something really
really stupid and it's stressing out my
brain quite a lot so what I've decided
to do to conflict my brain is wear a
cushion on my head
it's not really working I am still quite
stressed now but at least I now know
that I'm quite good at balancing a
cushion on my head in fact my motto is
you learn something new every time you
do something obscenely stupid and like
most stupid things in life the
explanation for this stupid thing starts
off with those four words that I hate so
dearly I have been challenged I have
been challenged by Laura loser three six
and nine to drink an entire bottle of
tomato ketchup Oh God maybe I'm not so
good at balancing cushions on my head
but anyway let's get down to business
it's time for me to make myself
obscenely ill my little sister oh she's
here she said she wanted to watch me
while I do this yeah she basically just
wants to watch me while I'm in pain my
sister's brought me this which I'm going
to put down here just in case I am sick
don't worry though
if I haven't sick at any point oh I
promise not to share it to you promise
right because when I see people be sick
I feel sick I've got strong it's good to
come prepared for this I'm already
feeling sick I haven't even started yet
I'm so stupid
why am I doing this my mum's just got
back home I hope she doesn't come up
here and see this ah
this is just going to be a video of me
sucking and then going and then sucking
more and going maybe a little end with
the climax of me being sick but we'll
see okay stop
as I had action is that this is horrible
so horrible or I'm gonna have to give up
I don't want to throw up everywhere I
feel like such a failure having not done
this but it's not it's not possible not
humanly possible I can't do it if anyone
else at home wants to have a go at doing
this then please don't it will harm your
innards and oh I don't know like anyone
can't speak words well there you have it
everybody something else that
charlieissocoollike cannot do we'll see
you next time on youtubers do the
craziest things
oh good bye